x factor's tom mann reveals the tragic
news that his fiancee danny hamson died
on their wedding day she was 34. her
cause of death is not yet known
[Music]
[Applause]
the former x factor uk contestant
revealed the heartbreaking news on
instagram alongside a black and white
photo of danny and their son bowie tom
writes quote i can't believe i'm writing
these words but my darling danny my best
friend my everything and more the love
of my life passed away in the early
hours of saturday morning 18th june
on what was supposed to be the happiest
day of our lives ended an irreversible
heartbreak i feel like i have cried an
ocean
we never made it to the altar or got to
say our vows or dance our first dance
but i know you know that you were my
entire world and the best thing that has
ever happened to me danielle
i will wear this ring that i was always
supposed to wear as a sign of my
unconditional love to you
tom made it clear in his message that
he's going to stay strong for their son
and although he admits he's completely
broken he promises danny to raise him
just the way they always wanted quote i
promise you he will know how amazing his
mommy was i promise to make you so so
proud tom also takes a moment to
describe his longtime love calling her
quote the most beautiful person inside
and out the most incredible soul he ends
his post by writing a message directly
to his beloved quote my darling danny
the brightest light in any room my world
is nothing but darkness without you i
will miss you forever
and now a ton of love and support is
flooding in the comments singer louis
capaldi simply writing quote love you
brother ellie golding offering her
condolences quote i'm thinking of you
non-stop you are so strong here for you
always love you
and spice girl emma bunton shares a
similar message quote heartbroken for
you a beautiful soul that will live on
thinking of you all
danny's final post a collage of photos
with tom and baby bowie on a family
vacation in sardinia italy last month
showing family meant everything to her
the couple originally planned to get
married in 2020 but had to postpone
their numptuals due to the pandemic and
when dany wasn't busy being a loving mom
and partner she was working in pr and
also known as a dancer she notably
appeared in harry styles 2021 music
video for treat people with kindness